imagine you buy a house for a million
doar million dollar a year later your
house is now worth
$300,000 let that sink in for a second
anyone in the short term would be like
dude what the hell is happening here now
longterm I think we all know that he's a
Visionary he's a builder I think he's
going to build this thing back up but
let's not pretend that whatever he
touches whatever he does just
automatically turns the gold I think
we're all fans of Elon I think we're all
seeing what he's doing with X formerly
known as Twitter
but this is not a good look not not a
good this is not a good look and last
point there is some preced in here so
you talked about stocks going up stops
going down we saw what happened to meta
Facebook when f Facebook changed their
name to meta tanked tanked now they're
up as high as ever but they turned it
around but their business model didn't
change and they weren't telling
advertisers to go themselves so
there is some uphill battle here with
Elon I